there's a monkey that basically he's the  alpha and he has like a group of women  that he [ __ ] and these little beta  monkeys stand on the top of the hill and  then what they do is they wait for when  um the king monkey the alpha monkey is  with one of his ladies and then they'll  debate a little pussio will run down and  then kill the baby the baby or could  like smash its head on a rock and then  it will still quickly Scuttle and hurry  away  the woman or the female monkey who then  grieve of that child and then we'll  actually go out and then go and seek  the the killer of the monkey the little  baby monkey and then looked to mate with  him  wow to show because what what would  happen is that guy or the king Alpha has  shown that he cannot protect The  Offspring so that's why she's looking  for  the protection survival of them you see  it so that sums up what Mike Tyson was  saying